Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Isn't that so crazy?
Like, literally any other vowel
would just not have worked.
We are about to talk about how
to access everything that's
inside of you to create a song.
(SINGING): I just
want you close.
Music is more powerful than
any other medium, period.
(SINGING): Where you
can stay forever.
If I wasn't an artist,
I would be a teacher.
The coolest teacher of all time.
We're going to go through
song writing, lyrics,
we're going to talk
about the process.
So we are in my vocal booth.
My vocal warm ups
sound pretty crazy.
Also going to bring
you into the studio,
talk production, how to
put everything together
to really create that beautiful
piece that you want to create.
If writing the song
is like the sketch,
arranging the song, and
particularly the vocals,
is like painting it.
We're going straight
to the heart.
Boom, direct.
To me, music is not technical.
It's emotional, and it
always has to emotional.
We're talking about
freedom of expression.
And sometimes you
have to get loud.
(SINGING): I keep on falling
in and out of love with you.
I'll never forget
the day they sang this.
(SINGING): --loved someone
the way that I love you.
Every day, you're different.
Every day, you're growing.
Every day, you're better.
I want to share with you
how to find your own voice,
how to trust it, too.
You know, you have something
to say the world wants to hear.
The world needs it.
Simple as that.
So if you're ready, I'm ready.
Are we ready?
Yes.
I'm Alicia Keys, and
this is my MasterClass.
(SINGING): Promise you, baby.
My love looks better on you.
Ting.
I need that real bad.
Can we please put
the ting in there?